hey 42 here when you buy something for
yourself whether it be a new watch or a
new car you probably spend hours
shopping around for the best deal on the
highest quality Browns you want to know
the exact features of the product some
of you may even desire to know how that
brand operates as a company is it
ethical does it use cheap labor and
cheap components however when we donate
money to one of the countless charities
out there most of us conduct no such
research we give it to an anonymous
person over the phone
internet or to a stranger with a
clipboard on the street and then we have
absolutely no idea specifically where
that money goes to what it buys or who
it helps at least that is the case for
the vast majority of charities but
perhaps you should start to take a
greater interest in the winding path
that your charitable donations take
because many of them lead to dead ends
or worse sometimes donating to a
charitable cause can actually make the
situation worse as I will soon discuss
if you want to do research on the
charities you are considering giving to
so you can discover whether your
donations are actually going towards
helping people or TV commercials then
the best place to start is the charities
financials in many countries including
the US and UK it is the law of medium to
large charities was published their
financial accounts and submit them to a
governing body such as the UK's Charity
Commission and sure enough you can visit
such websites and get a quick overview
of the exact income and delineated
expenditure of any large charity however
you don't have to be a forensic
accountant to make sense of it all there
are other nonprofits such as Charity
Navigator that keep a tab on the
spending habits of other charities as
well as investigating how they're run
and exactly what their funds are spent
on in order to mate each one yes that's
right there is a charity whose entire
job is to investigate other charities
using Charity Navigator you can see what
sort of philanthropic programs each
charity carries out and in what
countries and
money they put into each program but
this information is still rather vague
and all you can really use it for is to
ensure that the charity you are donating
towards isn't spending 60% of your
donation on posters with sad one-legged
puppies of them this information doesn't
give you the answer to the most
important question you really should be
asking will my donation to this charity
actually help the people or cause I want
it to help because throwing money as a
problem doesn't automatically fix it in
fact sometimes it can make matters much
much worse take for example the many
charities that install water pumps to
deliver clean water to a community one
point to a billion dollars of donors
money has been invested over the past 20
years to install a total of 60,000 hands
homes across sub-saharan Africa but
today 40% of those do not work and no
longer pump water they have
malfunctioned at some point and because
the community does not have the
resources or know how to fix the pumping
question it has fallen into disrepair no
more than an expensive well-intentioned
but useless and village ornament most
water pumps are manufactured in India to
low quality control and material
standards buying cheaper pumps allows
charities to make donations stretch
further and they can thus advertise that
they've delivered clean water to a
thousand communities last year instead
of just 500 consequently these budget
pumps soon break down the boreholes are
usually drilled incorrectly to because
of a lack of quality on-site engineers
and surveyors resulting in the pumps of
merging into the ground at an angle
instead of straight down which means
they will eventually stop delivering
water but one of the least effective
means of giving is when charity send
endless shipping containers full of
material goods to underdeveloped nations
this mostly consists of the developed
world
hand-me-downs charities such as Oxfam
and others will ship used clothes and
other goods to Africa if it doesn't sell
after a certain period of time on the
charity shop shelves more than 70% of
clothing donated to charity shops
globally ends up in Africa and Kenya
alone imports more than 100,000 tons of
clothes and other miscellaneous items
from global charities each year how else
could an overwhelming number of people
roam the streets of Kenya or Zambia
wearing I heart New York or Union Jack
t-shirts when they've likely never
visited America or Britain the issue is
that these mountains of regularly
imported clothes completely destroy
local textile industries the very
industries that have previously propped
up both local economies and supercharged
the national economic growth of many
African nations such as Kenya Malawi
Mozambique and Zambia all these have
burgeoning domestic clothing industries
before the boom of charities targeting
Africa from the 60s onwards the textile
industries have now overwhelmingly
vanished in these places in the 1980s
500,000 people were employed by Kenya's
textile industry today less than $20,000
largely this is because he immense
influx of second-hand clothes flooding
countries like Kenya has decimated the
demand for local textiles putting
hundreds of thousands of people out of
work and hence struggling to continue to
feed their families let's face it when
you're struggling to make ends meet
would you rather buy a locally made but
pricy t-shirt or a dirt cheap or
possibly free one from a market stall
that import some overseas charities
most people go into up to the latter
it's not only donated textile goods that
can devastate African economies and
shatter the prosperity of communities in
recent years there has been an explosion
of well-meaning charities that
specialize in donating electronic books
such as laptops tablets and phones to
African communities
the idea is that enabling Africans to
communicate will empower them to unlock
their economic destinies and get
reliable well-paid jobs or perhaps start
their own business
it's a lovely notion and the logic is
mostly sound but it is predicated on the
naive assumption that most Africans
don't already have access to mobile
phones this couldn't be further from the
truth try walking through a city such as
Kampala for five minutes once in the
heart of darkness now more connected to
the world than you would ever expect
only twenty years ago there were fewer
than four million mobile phones in all
of Africa today there are well over half
a billion handsets and more than 30% of
people in countries such as Uganda own
their own mobile phone there are used
handset stores on every street corner
and at every market in almost every town
and like the textiles that came before
this huge used mobile phone trade
constitutes a thriving business that
employs millions across the continent
and provides a sustainable income for
many small business owners who sell or
otherwise are connected to the mobile
market but each year there is a greater
influx of used unwanted handsets and
developed nations flooding places such
as Kampala the demand for mobiles in
Africa is increasing sure but the supply
is overwhelming that demand which
inevitably drives down the prices of
market vendors the vendors who make
their living from selling those devices
I believe and so do some experts that it
would be better for those charities to
look at ways to use their donation funds
to support the growth of these local
businesses that buy sell and repair
technology instead of footing those
markets with cheap overstock or
refurbished goods that will do the exact
opposite
to the community and what was intended
the same goes for food donations with
the exception of post disaster relief
sending mountains of tinned food to
developing nations only undercuts the
local food retailer
which means it never has a chance to
develop of its own volition and locals
who own a small shop or seller home
cooking at a street food store may be
forced to go out of business you could
apply this same logic to any form of
philanthropy based on the giving of
material goods for a nation to cut its
dependency on foreign aid it needs to
grow from the inside out by developing
its economy through local ingenuity and
the prosperity of local businesses which
inevitably have a trickle-down effect on
the entire community and if a region
needs to help a foreign aid to improve
its local services and infrastructure to
empower local businesses then that's
what charity should be focusing on
ultimately almost all forms of giving
that involve the handing over of
material goods and some services caused
a dependency cycle where the recipients
will begin to rely on that donated good
or service to survive over time the
community stopped producing those goods
and services locally and the entire
industries collapse which means as soon
as those donations dry or all the
charity focuses its efforts elsewhere
that region will be left devastated and
in a much worse position to sustain
itself than ever before as the old
proverb says give a man a fish and you
feed him for a day teach a man to fish
and you feed him for a lifetime but what
have I told you that your small donation
can actually cost a charity money when
any donation is made there is an
administrative cost associated with it's
a charity has to pay for web hosting
staff to maintain the websites and
payment systems staff and the IT systems
necessary to record the donation staff
to process the donation accounting staff
to enter each donation into the
accounting system and send that tax
receipts staff to bank donors which is
usually done over the phone email or
snail mail and finally reporting and
analytics
stuff the method of donation
significantly alters the amount received
taking a donation by cheque for example
costs a charity roughly ten times the
administrative cost to process when
compared to a credit or debit card
donation depending on the size of the
donation the donation method how that
charity operates and tens of other
factors by the time it is process your
donation can be reduced by up to fifty
percent and if you donate a very small
amount then the one-off processing costs
can actually exceed your donation
obviously all this varies wildly
depending on how each charity processes
its donations and how much it spends on
various aspects of the administrative
side of its business but next time you
donate you may want to consider a
slightly larger donation as the charity
will often see greater value out of it
because they will get to keep a higher
percentage of it after processing so I'm
sure when you give to charity you want
to make sure that a your donation money
isn't wasted and be your money actually
helps to make a real positive change to
someone or a community and thankfully
not all charities are created equally
there are some that do genuinely
transformative work instead of shipping
at mountains of semi useless goods to
Africa or elsewhere and today such
charities are much easier to find
because of the charities such as give
well we're established to review
individual charities and in their own
words search for the charities that save
or improve lives the most per dollar
they don't just analyze a charity's
financials they make site visits to the
offices and programs around the world to
comprehensively audit how effectively
those charities are using their donors
donations their top recommended
charities change from time to time so
it's worth going to take a look yourself
but they tend to be charities that focus
on medical support for common issues
such as malaria a vitamin deficiency and
worms since usually getting help to
overcome those illnesses is some
that sufferers are unable to procure
without outside help unlike a free
t-shirt so your donation will make a
real difference here ultimately who you
gives you and how much you give is your
choice but as a general rule of thumb
the more your donation translates into
those in need receiving even cash or
highly specialized services and not
material goods the better it will be for
the long-term prosperity of the
recipient thanks for watching I've just
launched my first book sticker flag in
it a thousand years of bizarre history
from Britain and beyond if you want to
get your hands on a first edition signed
copy then head on over to unbound
publishing the links in the description
and pledge today thank you